Why did the smartphone go to jail?
Because it was charged with battery!
Almost all smartphones that we come across
are rectangular in shape.
Why?
Why aren't they shaped in the form of triangles, circles, or maybe squares?
Let's find out.
First, let's talk about the uniqueness of a rectangle.
If we compare the area of a rectangle,
with the areas of a triangle, a circle, or a square of similar dimensions,
we see that the area of a rectangle is the greatest of all.
So is 'maximum area' the only reason?
Imagine reading text on a circular device.
Do you notice the empty spaces here?
The area isn't used efficiently.
Don't you think the same goes for a triangle as well?
Yes, so we can safely eliminate these two shapes!
Now, you may argue what's wrong with a square?
We can definitely use its area efficiently, right?
That gets us to an important point.
Let's hold both the smartphones,
in the shape of a square and a rectangle...
Now we increase the lengths of both the devices
such that they have the same height.
What do you see here?
Don't you think it'll be more difficult to hold this one
with one hand relative to this one?
Of course! So handling a rectangular device is easier.
Wait, there's more!
While reading the text, we prefer lesser width
as it's easier on our eyes.
And while watching a video, we prefer a wider lens!
Again the rectangular shape helps us here!
So, rectangle can be considered as the best shape
when it comes to smartphones.
Great!
Now for something interesting!
Flip your smartphone and focus on the camera region.
If you see carefully, the lens of the camera is circular in shape.
And the images we get on our display
are rectangular in shape.
What exactly is happening here?
Does the circular lens directly capture rectangular images?
Or does it capture circular images first
which are processed into rectangular images?
What do you think?
This Kyu Box is open for you to explore.
Do share your thoughts in the comment section below.
And don't forget to subscribe to our channel
to learn about awesome things.
Happy learning!